we cried our eyes out on that shot yes
we did the people making these movies
are those comic book nerds that
understand this entire world avengers
assemble
avengers was three years of nuts it was
three years of craziness whose idea was
it to put winter soldier with the shield
mine
that was all dumped 20 minutes before we
shot it you made that up 20 minutes
before you shot it yes
yo happy saturday guys we are back on
the couch as stuntman reacts and we got
our boy
james young here who is gonna give us a
special marvel edition that's right
marvel we're talking all the films he's
done from winter soldier to endgame
james tell them about yourself man hey
everyone my name is james i am a second
unit director action designer and
coordinator for film i started on
youtube back with a thousand pounds some
of our good friends and i was lucky
enough in 2012 2013 to do a little indie
movie called captain america winter
soldier and ever since then i've been on
this train that just doesn't stop i've
doubled a lot of the characters i've
doubled for sebastian stan winter
soldier i've doubled war machine iron
man a lot of the bad guys from avengers
so yeah i've been at the heart of the
design for the last 10 12 years so i
think i can give you some insight into
what's going on he's down playing it
check this out
has really changed the action that you
love right now and we're gonna watch a
bunch of clips and he's gonna break down
exactly how we got you guys so
so so hooked check it out
well
let's just jump right in
this is my scarlett took a nice little
click
that's a tough hit dish for scarlett to
do yeah running down on the knees a
little pad down
excuse me
surprise that's you huh yeah
i really broke my fist there that was oh
wow you're in a lot of this huh why is
it you and so much of this like i feel
like as an actor i would be like heck
yeah i get to do a fight scene you know
okay no it's a very very very valid
point so say sebastian breaks his arm
yeah i guess then you shut down the
whole movie exactly it's insurance at
the end of the day i mean the actors
will absolutely perform a lot of this
but at the end of the day if chris gets
hit or chris goes down production goes
down we're dealing with you know hyper
violence here we want to keep them as
safe as possible and that's our job is
to go as close to the line as possible
in the safest way but usually as well i
mean with the way that we're shooting
we're shooting so quickly i mean a lot
of you shot to the back of heads you
know so while i'm doing a shot here seb
is on the other unit blowing up cars so
we kind of interchanged back and forth
it's a way to get a lot of coverage done
in six days
this was actually the first thing we
shot in the street was me fighting chris
so it was it was
like the first time i'm ever in costume
and it's like yeah you're gonna do the
knife flip okay don't drop the knife
okay did you drop the knife ever the
knife flip was a bit of an interesting
thing because you don't really want to
flip a knife in combat right if you drop
it you're holding production up so no i
dropped it i think once on the day but
we did like three or four takes and then
moved on to other angles but it just
it's funny to me that people get so
enamored with it they love it yeah it's
a really iconic shot coming up with
certain little character things that you
know help people see the knife flip and
oh [ __ ] it's bucky so you got building
character it's a character and story
thing speaking of characters yes you're
a big nerd i want you guys to understand
that james is a nerd he's like me he's
like nico he's like you guys probably
watching this right now so being a nerd
right and you now are working on this
marvel film and you're designing this
fight whose idea was it to put winter
soldier with the shield mine that shot
right there was my idea like in terms of
the first thing you got to remember is
like you're building characters so i
treat it like a cyborg what's his prime
directive you're trying to kill captain
america okay so if i'm trying to kill
captain america you've done your
research what's cap's biggest weapon is
shield there you go you take the shield
away from cap it's a big thing but the
biggest thing for me was you go through
all the history of bucky and cap you
know that eventually bucky became
captain america so to me that was what
this was about right you're stripping
him sam does the side flip punching back
you get that one shot to show the future
i remember it being a really big moment
in the theater seeing bucky with the
shield yeah you know the fans are like
oh
but it also it's part of bucky's
character that shield has always been a
part of his life it's almost it's steve
himself and it goes into the falcon
winner soldier series with the fact that
you know the ownership over the shield
but who should have it like bucky should
but there's too much red i love what
they've done that shield is so iconic
you have to do something with it right
the knee on the day it was a one and
done
really yeah wow that's so rare yeah it
is red we only had one bronco so
then the hole that you see in the side
of the bronco there was what i just
smashed into now what we do is that
natural dent is that you actually just
denting the side of the car with your
body it is i have the pictures
so basically all i'm doing is standing
there i just have to open up you know
the timing is very important for me sam
is coming at me at full speed and he's
basically just going to get up and
scissor his knees and he's aiming just
to put me through that door my head
breaks the window oh that's a natural
head cracker it was it was part of my
head but maybe my shoulder see this was
six days of hell this was man i did more
stunt work in this opening sequence i've
ever done in my career and i did it all
with a severe injury really i separated
my shoulder i tore my biceps or my pec
tore my lats on my rotator cuff down the
middle two days before we did that's why
i have a big metal robot arm yep yeah
and the flying knee i can tell it's a
face replacement flying knee shot and
obviously in motion it flies by you
can't tell no but in the rest of these
shots there's got to be a lot of actual
chris evans fighting here chris did a
lot of this yeah chris is really good
with choreography he's got a tap dancing
bass so chris gets choreography like
that it's so impressive to me as a stunt
person to see an actor take 30 beats i'm
not kidding 30 watch him two times and
go can i just change this or this yeah
and then he'll do it it's rare and
that's what's great about chris for this
chris did two weeks and then literally
all right what's the next shot okay
chris you're gonna learn this whole
sequence where we do the knife flip okay
five minutes later he's ready to go we
did three takes and moved on wow again
all of this right here you have to watch
how chris is acting look there's no fear
there that's really hard chris has to
react to the knife flip right there's
these small moments in between that he's
hitting the again the moments in between
and what make the fights right yeah
right you can have beat one or b2 but
the more detail you program between b1
and b2 you're subconsciously programming
your audience
that sucked by the way was that onto
asphalt that was onto a little thin pad
like that
i did six of them man how do you not
crack the back your head on the ground
every time with a suplex like that the
biggest thing for this is just trying to
land flat my arm's coming down there you
see how i'm like that yeah then i can
roll over interesting because the roll
this dissipates your momentum and your
energy yeah it's time i'm holding you by
the waist yes the fact that he's holding
you by the waist allows you the
flexibility to open up and then retract
right yes it does and it's kind of like
you're going for a taco in his assisted
taco it is it is that's a tough one but
honestly here's the thing it's tougher
for sam sam is the one literally having
to pick up my weight not over rotate me
because if sam goes even further over
i'm coming down on collarbone so exactly
it's so important you know your dance
partners you gotta trust your dance
partner and sam hargrave is one of the
best dance partners in the industry and
that's why he's directing them
right
like one of the things i find super cool
about stunt work is how much of it is
like magic sleight of hand yeah in the
sense that like we're doing a suplex and
because i'm twisted three inches to the
left it's not gonna well it'll hurt but
it won't be as bad or as hard as an
actual impact versus if i was three
inches to the right it's all just like
that little hand movement that makes the
coin disappear it is all right so
there's a shot at the end of this fight
where aaron tony as falcon just blasts
james and he tells that story in the
extended version of this episode on
corridor digital.com that's right this
episode's actually eight minutes longer
over there you also get a bunch of other
cool shows the shows come out a day
early there's no ads and there's a two
week free trial so go check it out
quarterdigital.com
what do we do cap
we fight
you want to talk crazy splash panel
stuff or talk about this messy
awesomeness splash panel is like you're
reading your comic and then the fight's
about to start you turn that page and
it's a double spread all the characters
come in it's the big
poster shot that's a splash panel right
we cried our eyes out on that shaft yes
we did they had us all line up opposite
each other and on action we just ran at
each other and and there's my shoulder
tackle the jam sorry james did four of
those gee just let you spear tackle me
right in front of the camera
we designed this fight over a long
period before we even started physical
prep like actually going in and
designing previses myself and sam
hargrove the coordinators of the movie
we sat with kevin joe and anthony
dandelu and swen the head of vfx and we
sat down for a week maybe two weeks at
first six seven hours a day at a table
with the figurines of the and it is
basically the first week was all right
let's talk about the team makeups in
terms of story and let's put these guys
against each other and come up with a
list of hundreds of things that could
happen like we just came up with a
massive amount of lists of what if
natasha fought cap and originally she
fought him on the roof and we actually
shot the fight yeah so these teams
changed constantly
there's gig in here in the back
and getting thrown
is that your triple kick that was my
triple kick no wires right you just no
that was wired
that suit was so heavy he had the
toughest job i think the suit wise out
of all of us the black panther suit was
a beast of its own origin that thing is
incredible it looked incredible to look
at but i feel sorry for you
that was seven layers and it was pretty
much a restriction suit because they
built it on a mannequin the suit is made
to be like this so me lifting any kind
of arms or trying to lift my legs or
spread them it was constant battle it's
resistant bands but you know we all
worked together we all made it happen
that thing does not obey the laws of
physics at all at the time we did this
we didn't have spider-man tom holland
was not there yet there was no
spider-man at all until about a week
before we started shooting can you
imagine then what that does
my favorite moment ever at marvel is
literally called the movies it was tom
holland i was the one in tom's audition
there was something about him when he
walked in and he walks into our training
space and we've got all our cardboard
boxes up where we shoot our previouses
and at the time we had an air track an
air track is the bouncy little floor
that you can do flips on and tom looks
over this air track and goes hey do you
mind if i go flip i was like whoa
great absolutely not i say i don't know
if he goes no i can flip i swear but tom
proceeded to do front flash like a
repertoire of the really good basic flip
side flip front flip round off flash
round off back to like i'm like oh [ __ ]
he's got it he goes cool he goes so
tomorrow in the audition he's like do
you think it'd be okay if i flip and i
was like dude i was like listen i was
like if you flip and fall that's my
career i i can't have you do that but
you are auditioning for spider-man i'll
see you later
so what they did is they had the actors
come in in the spidey underwear suit the
one he wears in the first movie they did
this whole sequence of the hey that
shield doesn't obey the laws of physics
at all like they did the whole thing
they do it with the actors with chris
chris wow on his day off tom goes hey
joe um would you mind if i take my own
entrance and i just feel kevin joe and
all of them
go to me
[Laughter]
and tom
holland proceeds to skip in and throw
the most perfect side flip literally
straight past chris evans lands on his
mark goes hey cap how you doing spins
around with you like my suit
all you heard was
jaws
i got
goosebumps and tears in my eyes and you
could see and i even think joe was like
holy [ __ ] this kid just came in and just
that's peter parker that's peter there's
no other way about it so to see him come
in
and do that and literally leave the
heads of studios with their mouth on the
floor it was one of those most special
things i've ever witnessed and then to
finally design the cap and spidey fight
this spidey fight's so much fun what i
love about it is the way we play spidey
and tom in the first is that it's raw
talent there's no technique he's raw
this kid has watched professional
wrestling place it's so raw for him to
be doing this stuff and i love the way
that tom and marvin would perform things
a little bit out of control a little bit
off edge like he's learning
[Music]
the biggest thing for this fight was to
make sure that every character had a
moment that was the biggest thing was
everyone has to get a little win but it
was a long design it was a lot of redos
because you give one person a win over
another what does it do to the story so
it was a hard balance to find but then
again what's fit in the story where
we're going yeah it's it's a big puzzle
piece like this is a movie that has to
happen at some point around this fight
scene yeah yeah
exactly that's the thing you know we get
heavily into it so it's good to have
directors saying hang on right that's
not the story this whole sequence was
really fun for us but we died good times
[Laughter]
and then yeah then led into the final
battle
this final fight is actually interesting
because we did a big preview for it but
then i believe i think sets changed or
locations on sets change days changes
they always do so what you see is once
they start going hand-to-hand combat
down in the silo that was all done 20
minutes before we shot it you made that
up 20 minutes before you shot it yes
just things happen it happens you can
plan everything but it's a movie set
multiple things can happen someone's not
available this story new idea new set
well you better be good at you know it's
all about adapting
so that suit
is rough which is the captain america
no
oh wait i mean the iron man suits not cg
no it's a mix it's a mix this was the
last time we actually used a real kind
of suit so what i've got on here wait
you were iron man yes
that's cool man
yeah that's neat
pretty cool yeah the suit itself is like
american football pads and it is the
iron man suit it's got the light in the
chest the helmet is the real helmet with
the lights in it from waist below i'm in
red fleecy pajamas
and you know the digital markers on my
knees but the first time we did it i had
the helmet on i do a few takes with the
helmet on for reference and take it off
it was a real fun fun fight for me
such a cool sequence thank you we call
it piggy in the middle
what you've got to look at here though
is there's four people in this fight
count the four people
i'm going to guess it's the three main
characters in the shield yep oh
that shield's not there so during this
fight i'm not only having to fight seb
and chris but i'm having a track where
the imaginary shield goes so there's
times when i'm hitting i'll try and look
back hit the shield getting kicked i'm
just getting assaulted on all angles so
yeah this is all basically just the beat
down because robert and uh
you know chris had all this story they
wanted to so hey let's craft it with
that violence just push it as far as we
can go and yeah i think what you get at
the end of the day is great we talk
about robert oh rob it's an entity
robert's good he's so good he's so
brilliant at what he does like robert is
a martial artist as well so he's like
yeah he does wing chun right wing chun
for people that don't know is a chinese
martial art that is actually the nucleus
and base of jeet kune do which is bruce
lee's martial art what constitutes like
the main moves of chimes so a lot of
wing chun is a lot of uh down the center
line and there's a lot of no circular
movement essentially so like the idea is
attacking the center line because the
idea is i'm just going right down the
middle and if anything comes from the
outside i'm hitting i'm trapping i'm
doing all kinds of way to immobilize
your hands that's the way that you're
trying to do so rob works really well
with that you can see it in the scene in
the cafeteria he does the watch he
actually does a little bit of wing chun
okay so it's that's robert you know
biggest thing for your actor is do what
they're great at right right you don't
want to go hey look you great wing chun
you keep it into what the base is and
when i designed for iron man on these
movies i would meet robert and you know
he would always want to incorporate some
of that so take all my notes and we
always try and incorporate that into the
iron man aspect because it's it's he's
the heart of it yeah it's a bummer we
won't get to see him there anymore but
man he gave us the innings
he gave us it all
i love hard hits and stunts if you guys
know some really hard hits please leave
them in a comment below so we can pull
out the scenes and look at them exactly
and get an understanding as to just how
hard those hits were from the pros on
this couch so please leave a comment so
it's really cool when you think about
how civil war kind of sets us up for the
even bigger hero avengers one and two
you get maybe six superheroes all
sharing the screen civil war you have to
share it with nine to ten now we have to
get to avengers infinity war end game
where you're sharing it with the whole
cinematic universe that we have up to
this moment and you guys still found a
way to juggle the idea of we need to
give each of these guys their moment
it's a hard one because you're going
into this like you're going into all
right we've built up 15 years of this
right cap is going to fight the big bad
i'll call it cap salvo or cap's end game
and that's when he gets the hammer
[Music]
we shot multiple reveals of the hammer
as well we shot it coming off the ground
we shot different ideas and of course
the one that's in the movie is so much
fun just the hammer lifting up but the
question is then as an action designer i
think as an action team is how do you
give cap the hammer and do something
cool crazy what do you do just swing it
what we wanted to do
was
kind of
give you everything that's the whole
idea of foreshadowing
[Music]
you watch cap
go at him with the hammer every one of
those moves cap has done before
everything there is a story piece you've
seen it before it's it's so that was the
idea they were trying to give something
impactful it's difficult but it's crazy
like just the amount of detail and
thought it's not just a throwaway punch
punch here's a cool move it's like every
move is character development massive
big ups to justin eaton and danny
hernandez here justin was like captain
america and danny was our thanos so yeah
justin did all this in one the whole the
whole combo is really impressive yeah
man avengers was three years of nuts it
was three years of craziness different
style of movies to make than the captain
america movies you know you're more
space there's bigger stakes there's a
lot more big stuff it's not like little
pilly hand-hand combat when one of your
characters can literally cleave a guy in
two you treat this movie less like an
actual movie more like an anime it's
really different for action it's like
almost abstract because you're not
thinking about punches you're thinking
about these abilities and it's way up
there like crafting a fight of hand tank
combat easy easy crafting a fight with
only hadouken shiroukens and tetsumaki
sempyakus that's hard right right so
that's the idea that's the idea the vast
majority of people i feel like are
watching all the marvel movies as just
movies right but then there's a smaller
sliver that's read all the comic books
and understands the context within the
whole comic world that these movies are
coming out in and there's so much more
nuance in these films for that comic
book crowd i'm constantly surprised by
how much there is yeah so i'm always
assuming it's just like you know there's
just disney making movies like no like
the people making these movies are those
comic book nerds that understand this
entire world and they're making it just
for that group first and then everybody
else gets to watch it second kevin's the
head of it like his mind is incredible
he knows everything about these when it
all connects he's the mastermind he's
the thanos it's incredible what he's
done it's groundbreaking you know
there's people out there who are like
you know talk about superhero movie
fatigue and you know that's just another
marvel film but i think like we really
take it for granted that these films
exist yeah and these are the pinnacles
of execution when it comes like cinema
you know like these crazy the action the
visual effects the storytelling the
writing the production the coordination
and the engineering and the problem
solving that goes into these like it is
hundreds of the people that are the best
of the best in the world coming together
to make these yeah and it's cool if you
don't like you know everybody
everybody's the things they don't like
but it's definitely important to
acknowledge like that these are truly
like achievements in cinema yeah anyway
yeah movies all right let's play a
little game i'm going to say something
and if you've done it you have to
subscribe if you're not subscribed
have you seen a marvel film
boom everybody subscribed all right job
over
james has been an absolute treat to have
you join us on the couch thanks man i'm
sad that this is ending i'm sure all of
the watchers to the audience is sad that
this is ending but if they wanted to see
more of your works and behind the scenes
or keep up with you where can they do
that hit me up on instagram at ju10 i'm
pushing more stuff out on it now i'm
gonna be putting up more behind the
scenes stuff from not only my marvel
days but uh from my new stuff i'm doing
with netflix like the grey man and stuff
like that so yeah stay tuned he'll be
there i love behind the scenes posted to
instagram like every stunt breakdown
it's like in a way just it grips me more
than movies themselves because it's so
real it's so rough i love her thank you
so much it's been an absolute pleasure
and you can probably get through the
other seven marvel movies i did yeah
we've only scratched the screen he
scratched the tree with rim yeah we did
like a black middle
gosh black widow guardians two avengers
two three avengers four guardians one
cap one you know they're all there on
disney plus
[Laughter]
that's it we'll see you guys in the next
one thank you so much for joining us